it wasn't sort of a panic impulse
response but it was I have got to get
this girl away from this guy now because
these guys call all the shots and thank
God she collapses backwards and she
falls backwards in the rebel can hang on
to what a shackle I step over her and
over her legs and just stand there I'm
sure I was scared and I'm furious and
I'm all out of options now there are no
cards left to play now there's no
subtlety left it is now time to call it
someone took my knife I want my knife
back someone took my knife and I want my
knife back I want my knife back
someone took my knife
there was this massive pregnant pause
among everybody and I looked at the
commander and I can remember all these
faces turn to see what he was gonna do
about this and I thought how they kill
us okay they kill us but nobody moves
nobody did anything everybody just kind
of stayed there what else do you want
from us why are we here robbed us
humiliated us gonna tell me that
somebody took my night but I want my
knife back who's got my knife I don't
think a cricket squeaked and I look at
the commander and he looked at me and he
just kind of smiled
honey let me cut him and then almost
right away paper and pen were produced
and he writes all this stuff down he
hands it to me and says read it
all of Africa's at war when we come back
no talk no negotiating no hostages we
kill everyone on the spot
I reiterated my promise that I would
personally put it in the hands of the US
ambassador and I put it in my pocket
and then they turned and walked off and
we were totally alone no rebels no
nothing just us
I don't think any of us knew quite what
to do right away it was so total and so
fast to change and then it was you know
we have got to go we have got to get out
of here but it's not a joyous loud
raucous occasion it's it's surprisingly
somber but we had hours of difficult
hiking ahead of us